[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today I spoke about a project that I've
been working on for about a year called
style components get ready for the
future of CSS statement CSS is real
development and we do value it CSS MJS
you should definitely do a personal
project that is quite ambitious together
and then you can get amazing results art
history and its relationship with CSS
optimizing the delivery of our CSS and
other critical resources on the webpage
how CSS gets made really I'm basically
lab coding a CSS game for everybody here
today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what I love about the conference is the
how the talks are scheduled in near
twine and the balance of technical and
non-technical remarkable group of people
such a collection of skills and
backgrounds I just feel like the
entirety of the conference is so well
done and thoughtfully done that's that's
what makes me excited to come to it
because I know that about it people are
all in one place at the same time and
then during our actually outside and
talks people can communicate and talk
about things they've just heard well I
mean that the first thing is definitely
offering chakra in the first place you
are one of the first conferences that
I've ever heard that's done that it's
actually made a much warmer safer
environment for everyone in the future
maybe you put together a personal
project maybe you come to the conference
and you see someone speak and you say
hey I can do that and you submit a
proposal and then you're on stage next
year I just met somebody who implemented
CSS grid in browsers I never really get
to talk to the actual implementers of
these things that I use in love I feel
like every couple of years there is
something new and there's something new
to learn and this conference has the
best people to teach you the best things
[Applause]
[Music]
we have of course a bigger venue and
more opportunities for people to
interact the best part is that despite
the bigger venue or thanks to the bigger
venue the community spirit remains the
same I think we need these events to
bring diverse and different positions
together we need all those people from
different countries in one room to
actually make progress and come to new
insights and I think it's already
happening here today and that's great
and like over the years it feels like a
big family reunion every year
[Music]
you